how do you handle hecklers best type of
story you do I mean don't do it on
on purpose don't do to other people and
if you do it it's like there's a
boundary of it but I like love doing
crowd work so I'm like [ __ ] bring it
it's annoying if someone's interrupted
if someone's drunk someone interrupts
the middle of a joke it's like [ __ ] I'm
like in the middle of this but I have
sometimes I just have to like break the
fourth wall and be like I got add [ __ ]
I can't handle this like this isn't
gonna work for all of us if you keep
doing this I try my best to not get
people kicked out like I wait as long as
I possibly can
if they're really disrupting the show
they'll go but sometimes the show just
becomes about them and hopefully the
audience funny enough for the audience
that they're not like feel like but you
don't get intimidated you don't get
you're like let's go
you can't I don't think you should ever
be mad on stage if you show like anger
or fear or something it's like because
it's a it's a you're in a position of
power these people are trusting you to
be in to control the control of the
audience for but I had um I had a guy
who I'll tell you two Heckler stories
this was the worst one I was at The
Comedy Store this guy had been heckling
the comedian before me and it was
[ __ ] pissing me off I was [ __ ] mad
I was [ __ ] hyper Vigilant like I'm
gonna [ __ ] this guy up so I went on
already pissed and um he was this like
British guy this older British guy was
wasted and um it was Halloween and I
just did kind of like a hacky Your mom
joke where I just went on it's so weird
like that you're here you know because
I've been planning my costume I was
gonna go as your mom for Halloween but I
really couldn't fit I couldn't fit all
the dicks in my mouth it just wasn't big
enough and the man got so mad it was
hilarious he got so pissed so then he
stands up he's like don't talk about my
and I'm cocky thinking security is
around but this was back in the day when
The Comedy Store was not what it was
what it is now it had a little lapse in
uh security for a second but I thought I
was good so I'm talking so much [ __ ] to
this guy he stands up he goes don't ever
talk about my mom I go oh my God I
didn't realize your mom was like that
big of a [ __ ] that you thought I would
actually know her like I don't even I'm
not even from your country right like
I'm not doubling down [ __ ] you we're on
the show so then he starts to charge the
mound like he's coming at me and I'm
like uh security security and they got
him someone got him right before he got
on the stage but it was like I almost
got [ __ ]
big time but it would have been even
though I don't want to get hit it would
have been a very funny joke afterwards
that's another thing that's great about
being a comedian any moment of
discomfort discomfort becomes something
great right
um and then
um a fun one was I was in St Louis and
the club that I was at did not have
um food so people were in full blackouts
I mean they were wasted but so I
anticipated the second night so I had
um the guy that was like working on my
rider and stuff he went I had him I go I
have an addition to my rider I need two
loaves of bread so he brought me bread
and butter and so this girl kept
heckling and I shoved bread in her mouth
yeah I was like all right you're in
trouble now open your mouth because she
was wasted were people dying it was the
funniest thing in the world and then I
was just like throwing I was like who's
hungry I was just throwing pieces of
bread out to everyone like frisbees it
was great I have footage of it I gotta
cut it off you have to come back it was
great